bang-bang what's up guys lunch money
time while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right I'm here with the beautiful
intelligent plain of Mara Nova today
she just got normal clothes on I don't
know what no I'm sporty today okay we
won't tell the people how unathletic you
are not very athletic but let's get into
tick-tock what's going on with tick-tock
so tick-tock is you know tick-tock the
short-form video app that is used by
teens and sometimes adults who should
not be on there
if I was on tick-tock I would be a star
I'm not on tick-tock but if I was watch
out
so Tic Tacs owner byte dance is a China
based company that reportedly made a
profit of three billion on seventeen
billion dollars of revenue last year I
mean that's absurd I mean look I
actually think that's low which people
disagree with but think about it
they've over 2 billion downloads they're
like as big as Facebook is Facebook's a
four hundred billion dollar company
that's got all this monetization and
it's been able to grow and scale a
massive business in the public markets
fight dances reportedly valued somewhere
between 100 and 110 billion dollars they
did 17 billion in revenue three billion
dollars in profit and they suppose they
have six billion dollars a cash on hand
I just think it's a small business
compared to what they've been able to do
from a download and user basis what I
find fascinating is that the US
government keeps trying to kind of like
get it shut down by saying that you know
there's a wall you know security
concerns how they store their data
censorship of content and it doesn't
matter because the biggest stars on
tik-tok are us-based
yeah Logan we want to talk about
censorship we might as well shut YouTube
down because you saw recently I don't
know for anyone who didn't see there was
terminology that's used to describe the
CCP every time you would comment that on
a YouTube video it was automatically
deleted and when YouTube got called out
on this basically they worse they said
oh whoops that was by accident so it's
just it's all nonsense right
well let's go back to technocracy the
reason why I say this is because when I
was at Facebook in 2014 2015 we had a
billion users but the business was much
much bigger and so the whole idea is if
you think about the average revenue per
user for tik-tok they actually don't
have that big of an advertising surface
right
yesterday when I looked at tick-tock may
now run an ad so you open the app
there's an ad of Jennifer Lopez who I'm
assuming goes to everybody that's gotta
be a ton of revenue and then obviously
they put ads in the stream but for
Facebook for example what they were
doing is everything from feed ads to
mobile ads to the head gaming revenue
like they had a much more by versified
revenue stream I don't think that
tick-tock has that yet the hope here and
what is potentially an opportunity for
investment is that people who own equity
in the company today can grow into a
Facebook like company because they
learned how to monetize better but 17
billion sounds like a big number except
for if you look at how much users how do
you feel it being a China based company
look I get the concerns if you don't
want to use the app don't use the app if
you want to use the app use the app like
I don't understand what the big deal so
what are you gonna do when it's I mean
yes for you and me and whatever but like
the bunch of the users are 14 year old
girls what do they know about what
China's doing with their data and all
that stuff but again if you're putting
content on the Internet you're making a
conscious choice to put your data out
there right and so do you think that
people aren't doing that on Facebook or
YouTube or Twitter or whatever if you
take photos and put them on the Internet
you're contributing to public
information but you're now you're
dealing with the Chinese government what
do you think the Chinese government
doesn't have that it doesn't have access
to the Internet of course they're just
great they'll just scrape it off
Facebook they'll scrape it off Twitter
it'll scrape it off Google right and so
the whole idea is like again this is the
classic balance between convenience and
security if you want to have a super
secure new surveillance world get rid of
all of your electronics when you have
kids what are you gonna tell your
children everything you put up there is
gonna last forever okay I just want to
put you know dance videos on tick-tock
that's fine knock yourself out but like
again we're operating in a world where
used to be the default was you had
privacy and oh my god did an Interphone
get posted
now everyone's operating in a world
where default is public and they're
sharing and sharing and sharing there's
obviously benefits that come with that
we get all this great content
entertainment information whatever
there's also downsides to it you just
got to be smart by the way we screwed up
what we forgot this episode is sponsored
by block five get money get paid BAM you
guys thought you could skip through the
ads no you can't I get you with the
block fly ad because I forgot
but block guys got three products you
can deposit crypto and they'll give you
a u.s. dollar loan you can deposit and
earn up to eight point six percent APY
unheard of interest rate or you can buy
and sell crypto go check them out at the
link in the description will tell you
more after the episode but I ain't
forget get money get paid speaking of
getting paid let's talk about Zuk Zuk
Zuk s-- is it Zeus or Zeus it's zu with
an X I always call it zu X likes X is
ooo X I think it's called Suk's
not just be confused with the dating app
zoosk okay we won't we won't go there
men date sidestep let's keep going
what's going on with Zuk Zuk
amazon is in advanced talks to buy
Zuke's which is the self-driving car
tech company um what the hell is amazon
doing in autonomous driving well first
of all zooks is not an autonomous car in
terms of they're not making the cars
they're just add on technology so take
your regular car and you can basically
pimp it out with all this stuff all
those cameras and stuff and then now it
turns your car into a self-driving car
well think about it
what is Amazon a lot of people forget
Amazon a very very big part of their
business is to build the largest
logistics network in the world right
they're trying to compete with FedEx and
UPS and all this stuff so what is going
to be an inflection point or a major
leap forward in that race is going to be
who can get to autonomy first right if
all of a sudden you now have a fleet of
autonomous cars that can do deliveries
whatever
everyone knows robots driving your car
that's fine then also what if they can
have robots who actually deliver for all
of the Amazon Prime stuff or what about
if you have delivery for all their Whole
Foods grocery shopping right like that
is where the world is going and so
Amazon is probably going through a
builder by exercise and if these people
have great technology then of course
you're going to end up just buying them
because Amazon's got ungodly amount of
money right Jeff Bezos went through a
divorce lost 30 billion dollars he's
still the richest man in the world
unbelievable
okay do you think that this is a good
idea for them to buy it honestly I was
just thinking if I was at games on had
an unlimited amount of capital I just go
buy everything well that's kind of what
they're doing the talking about buying
AMC Theaters they already bought whole
foods though maybe buy a self-driving
company they bought pill pack do we want
to live in an Amazon Jeff Bezos world is
the question yes
think about what Jeff Bezos has done for
commerce and for advancement I know but
I'm not a fan of monopolies okay but the
whole idea of why did it become a
monopoly right and by the way I don't
think it's a monopoly but it's
defecating clothes the whole idea is
they had better technology they have a
better company the reason why you order
from Amazon so they can get you goods
cheaper and faster than anyone else if
you if they couldn't you'd go somewhere
else that is the beauty of a free market
yeah but they're kind of stifling
innovation and competition that's why I
can't go to any videos how by buying
everything Shopify is doing just fine
Shopify is a competitor to Amazon
Shopify is helping everyone else and
their stock is on an absolute tear okay
as Shopify says they're trying to arm
the rebels because Amazon's like the the
Goliath and the rebels are the David's
in this scenario and that's what Shopify
is trying to do so now you have a
Shopify purse Amazon showdown
I don't think Shopify is anywhere near
Amazon scale or no but there's a
difference business that's the beauty of
it so Amazon is vertically integrated
that's the whole beauty of Amazon's
business model is that Jeff Bezos
understood he put a wedge in through
books right I'm gonna get you guys to
buy books online he's talked too much
about why he started with
and then as he went horizontal to other
verticals to sell online he also
realized if I can get vertically
integrated ready the store online plus
the supplier fulfillment centers plus
the transportation network plus AWS plus
all this stuff which you get that
vertical integration is you get massive
efficiencies of scale which is what he
has good for him you know what he should
be the richest man in the world he built
the most powerful company in the world
probably okay so next her speaking of
losers they're losers okay but speaking
just your transitions need to get better
um am I kidding glide coaching okay
hurts you know it filed for bankruptcy
the other day on Friday
now things are coming out that it paid
sixteen point two million in bonuses
days before declaring bankruptcy
important words here the company did not
pay sixteen point two million dollars in
bonuses days before they yeah well guess
what
this is cuz you're reading car scoops
calm pop scoops calm it is the
executives paid themselves sixteen point
two million dollars in bonuses to a
broad base of key employees at the
director level and above go ahead there
were given the money and recognition of
the financial and operational
uncertainty of the company given the
corn virus pandemic extra work done by
them as a result cutting thousands of
jobs and the forfeiture of their
participation in the company's usual
bonus plan so again we have a company
that is running out of money and
literally as they were shutting down
getting ready to file for bankruptcy
they hit a quick bonus button and the
bonus button fired off sixteen point two
million dollars to all the executives
directors except sure what they did if
you are paid into the crypto world this
is called an exit scam this is a
corporate exit scam as it's going out of
business
grab as much cash as you can but the
problem is they took that from
shareholders the shareholders of the
business you have a stake to that
capital yeah so so I was reading this
the other day about how basically Hertz
has so much debt it takes two pages of
small print to summarize and this
Financial Times reporter says Hertz is
basically a bank that rents cars well
because what they basically do is of
that 17
I think it's 17 billion dollars in debt
yeah 13 billion of it is in asset-backed
loans or securitizations
that's how they basically get all the
cars right is they're doing a bunch of
financial engineering but look at the
end of the day
speaking of self-driving cars
how about uber has decimated these
rental car companies right when you go
to the airport now
right on the way there or when you land
in a new city I don't rent a car as
pull-up uber right bang-bang by the
laser they're legitimate somebody needs
to say this so I'm just gonna say it
she's gonna get mad at me these people
are scumbags for what they did like that
is the scummiest of scum things to do i
tweeted this an article yesterday and i
said in the army there's a saying that
eat leaders eat last right so is the
whole idea let's say that you have you
know a whole team of soldiers underneath
you every time you go to eat they go
first you eat last if there's no food
left over you just don't eat but you
always take care of them before you take
care of yourself but that hurts they
don't eat last they literally took the
money last and then walked out the door
and so it's just look at the end of the
day they're not gonna get punished it's
gonna go by they're gonna you know use
all their corporate speak to say this is
why he were getting the bonuses but it
just shows that corporate america is
super greedy and they do things that may
not be illegal but i would consider them
to be unethical and what is the
coronavirus expose every sham in society
speaking of something that is not a sham
some stack so if you've been paying
attention on twitter and to lunch money
more and more reporters are just leaving
their media organizations and trying to
do the independent journalist thing and
joining sub sac
we're big big fans of sub stack over
here subsidized so do i yeah we were
some of the earliest users
and their whole thing is they basically
said how can we help
creators people who write for
newsletters how do we give them the
tools to do this independently and help
monetize their work and align the
company's sub stack with the Creator now
all of a sudden what's happening is all
these reporters are realizing wait a
second all a media company is it's like
a talent agency they go and they get a
bunch of talent they tell them work
we're gonna pay you a set salary and
then we're gonna take all your work and
we're gonna sell it to people whether
it's advertisers or the consumer and
then even if you provide more value over
time we're gonna keep paying you this is
how every company or itself yeah but the
difference is that most employees like
if you're an engineer at let's say suits
you can't go out and just start your own
self-driving company without raising
tons of money and like having a whole
team and can't do your own by yourself a
reporter just has to write so literally
they could do their work on their own
and just get people to pay them directly
for it right it's similar to like being
a carpenter at a carpentry company you
could leave you just be a carpenter by
yourself and a lot of times like
especially if you're you know one of
these people who write a newsletter say
the media organization you can kind of
see that like based on what you write
advertisers are paying for right so I
mean you could go and do it on your own
you could do something else but it's
just it's interesting because now as
media organizations find themselves in
these tough times and they have to lay
people off I think more reporters are
starting to think like oh [ __ ] like what
what do I have going for me that I can
monetize yeah and here's the part
remember what I said about Shopify
arming the rebels against Amazon sub
stack is technically arming the rebels
against legacy media right they're
giving the tools if you want to go be an
insurgent leave and go fight your fight
well you did it yeah read the profile
wrong Alex Kantrowitz
is the latest to leave he left BuzzFeed
he was like the lead tech reporter there
does fantastic work and and his leaving
he's a sort of podcast he's gonna start
this newsletter and so good for him
think it's so it's cool all right Ford
SUV in the ridiculous story of today
what are these these it's not
okay okay wait let me preface the story
with yesterday we went on a walk and we
walked past the police station and all
these technically the the special
operations of the New York Police
Department's like the SWAT team okay so
we passed them and they were coming out
and they were joking with each other
what are one of them say like hey you
clean that car you clean my car did you
clean my car and he and they were
switched they were like basically doing
a shift change and two of the guys were
getting out of one car and two of them
were going into the car and no lie they
literally were had like some kind of
distance disinfectant spray masks all
this stuff and they were like cleaning
like you would see you know the
janitorial service clean Robin and and
the whole thing is that there's lots of
germs that officer in those cars if
you're constantly putting people in and
out of the cars
then the germs but you know how you
could keep the germs spread down leave
people alone don't put them in the back
of the car don't arrest them but that's
a whole other thing so what's what's
Ford gonna do to help them okay so
because of coronavirus the New York City
Police Department asked for a better way
to sanitize its vehicles because I guess
they don't want to be scrubbing down
everyone the cops are probably like yeah
I started to be a police officer I
decided to wash down the car every day
so Ford created software that will burn
the germs out of the police department's
SUVs so it will basically it will raise
the interior temperature of the car not
133 degrees Fahrenheit for 15 minutes
apparently this is a solution to
coronavirus guys don't believe it know
this that's hot enough and long enough
to kill more than 99% of disease-causing
germs in the vehicle including the
corona virus so I used to believe this
theory and then I did some research and
I thought if I went in the sauna that I
wouldn't get Corona bodiless because
it's just the heat will kill it and then
I learned that that's not true and so
somehow Ford believes that it's true you
can kill it with heat I'm sure that
there is some benefit to doing this but
I do not buy that we're gonna turn the
cars basically we're gonna do is we're
gonna have bio defense mode that's
absolutely what they're doing they're
gonna just burn the hell out of it by
making it 133 degrees for 15 minutes
then cool it down and all of a sudden
all the disease
is gone Florida better hope that this
thing doesn't malfunction with people in
there they call it send you like a
getting hot I'm not buying this at all
but by the way look it's cool they
trying to use technology it's a new
software update to their cars I love
that they're trying I just don't think
that that's gonna be the answer you can
see how this goes wrong in a whole bunch
of ways and you know look wait till
somebody says oh for you're now selling
cars on the fact that there's no viruses
they go and they do some tests they
prove it's not right and then there's a
lawsuit against for we live in a in a
screwed-up world but hey good for them
for trying all right
ready what's up with SpaceX SpaceX man a
big day today big day I'm so high I woke
up this morning the only thing I hear is
oh man there's a SpaceX hype video yeah
I mean listen SpaceX and NASA launch the
height video today it called launch
America and it's just like you know it's
like Monday Night Football SpaceX
launches like let's go god I miss sports
for you um so space is bigger than
sports
SpaceX raised three hundred forty six
point two million in its most recent
funding round Wow
and that cares well they've raised
they've raised billions of dollars let's
get to the good stuff
what's going on with the space take off
all right space take off you can watch
it live today I think it starts in like
4:30 p.m. Eastern Time is what it's
supposed to happen but livestream starts
earlier than that
so yeah it's exciting so they're gonna
take two astronauts they're gonna launch
them into space these are the first
manned space flight from the United
States since 2011 in almost a decade
we've been paying Russia eighty million
dollars a seat to take our astronauts up
to the International Space Station we're
gonna put two dudes in the crew Dragon
capsule we're gonna launch them to space
with a reusable rocket we're gonna land
the rocket back here on earth then they
are gonna go up into space they are
going to autonomously ah connect the
Dragon capsule to the international
space station our two astronauts are
gonna lock their little asses you're on
to the International Space Station if
you on mosque you must be sweating right
now you must be like oh [ __ ] like this
has got to go well no I think what's
happening right now is you're probably
pretty in the zone of just like let's
make sure we do everything right and you
you haven't yet had the opportunity to
realize the gravity of the situation
because he's so focused him and the team
remember they say a whole team effort
here this is not Elon Musk only this is
SpaceX the whole team is so focused on
let's make sure we get it right yeah
right and then after the fact you'll see
if this works
they'll go nuts I mean if this works if
this works means if these guys don't die
and make it there so like yeah look but
you got to remember the only way that
they're gonna actually do this launch is
if they have a very very high
probability and confidence level that
it's gonna work one two is I think that
there's only been a handful of times
where we've gone to launch actual humans
now there's been other issues but with
humans in them I know the Challenger
there might be one or two others where
there's been issues and especially where
it's blown up and we do a lot of across
the world launching on people into space
and so it's actually not that common for
there to be issues but people in all of
technology and business we talked about
the zoning out I though back in so you
know what so you know how normally like
these astronauts who what said it I said
there weren't astronauts sorry I zoned
out what you say you know I normally
astronauts are like they have this Long
Goodbye and like they leave a lot of
their family behind when they go to on
these missions whatever do they ever not
leave their families be well this is
cool because both of them their wives
are also astronauts oh the two
astronauts going up to space today both
of their wives are astronauts it's cool
what you think they just were like hey
should we go on a double date to the
International Space Station
now would you go on a double date to the
space station no just in the in the
capsule and go to space no why I don't
like roller coaster so I feel like I
don't want to be launched I don't want
to be like shot up I'm speechless I'm
speechless guys that's it for much money
today
Wall Street is trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right
hopefully pallino will stay awake for
tomorrow's episode gravity is cool what
gravity is cool where'd that come from
well cuz you don't want to be shot up
for lunch okay anyway okay we'll see you
guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on I'm an investor a
user and a huge fan what you're a bigger
fan of block fire than you are of me
block wise my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina
they've got three products they can give
you a u.s. dollar loan you can earn up
to eight point six percent interest on
an interest-bearing account or you can
buy and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
it's pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at block by subscribe to our
channel like the video annoy playing in
the comment and we'll see you guys
tomorrow
and be kind to your friends